Tình như bạn, bà xa này, ta kia chi nghe 1 bội tâm emu trò biết
bà sẽ chỉ đạo nội cá mất đầu xây dự 1 kể hoạt tại khoa mới
kéo dành dầu năm từ tháng 1 năm 2020
nhằm thay thế hệ thống kiểm soát ngon 2 hệ này
theo bà ta kia chi chính phủ sẽ không lập tất, vì bỏ một điều cân bằng ngon 3 hệ
nhưng cần một quân khổ linh hoa thân để vừa kiểm soát lơ
vừa có thể chì điều cho tăng trưởng và an suy ra hội
mà cho rằng cách lệng giản nân xác theo tình năm đã lỗi thời
vì khiến chính phủ khó phà lưỡng trước các biến đất khi tế lớn
đông thái này được xem là bất ngọt trong chính xác tại chính buộc tục yếu
khi các chính phủ trước bà ta kia chi luôn trụ trọng việc là thọng dư nân xác tư bàn
tất tân bằng tu chi mặt không cần vài thêm lợt
tuy nhiên trong nhiều năng qua, nịch bàn lý tục phải hãng lục điều này
để tông ra các gọi chi t yêu biết cầu và hỗ trợ người dân sau đại dịch
ngoài ra thuộc dường xa là a ta kia chi khủ trò biết
chính phủ sắc công buồn gọi chi tiêu mời nhằm ở phó chi phy sinh hoa ta khao
tăng đầu tư bộ cuối phòng và tăng ngành công nghệ bu nhỏ
rồi có xanh nhật đi, tốt kêu đàn lỗ lực tìm điểm cân bằng giữa
để tài trình hứng và nhu cầu tục đại tăng trường
trong bối cạnh nợ công của nhật đã lượng gấp đôi quy mô lên kinh tế